I was thinking today about you as Annie
and misery and I know the distinction
there is that there are so many horror
characters out there that it's hard to
crack through and I think you created
one of the all-time great sort of horror
movie scary characters a completely
different twist really an amazing thank
you no thank you
my mother wouldn't have greeted what I
wouldn't have agreed with you know she
didn't know what she was she not a fan
of that rule she saw it and she said she
didn't know what all the fuss was about
that she had actually seen that behavior
[Laughter]
she just thought you were playing
yourself
exactly right she used to hobble
everybody yeah were you were you a
troublemaker when you were a kid um
devious it depended on the time yeah you
know when I was a teenager I was pretty
irritable irascible yeah
difficult to live with well you know my
parents were my dad was born in 1900 my
mom was born in 1907 so imagine going
through the 60s right when they're in
their sixties I mean it just didn't
quite jive didn't quite jive you know
it's funny we have someone who works
here at the show who I think they have a
relative who went to your school and
they have the same yearbook so we have
your yearbook and I was looking no I
have to say you you look like oh I don't
imagine any trouble coming from this
person you actually look like a very
lovely
lovely person there you know what are
you yeah you were kind of a square oh
yeah you went through that face yeah
yeah I wasn't you know I wasn't hip at
all right yeah yeah well it wasn't easy
I was hip in my day it's a big burden to
be so cool in high school I guess so you
dodged a bullet
gone down after that
so where anyone but you
you